welcome to the hubermann lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
i'm andrew huberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology at
stanford school of medicine today my
guest is dr emily balchettis dr
balchettis is a professor of psychology
at new york university her laboratory
studies motivation goal setting and
tools for successful goal completion
i learned about dr balchetta's work some
years ago because i'm a vision scientist
that is i study the visual system and i
heard about this incredible psychologist
at new york university who was studying
how
vision that is how we visualize problems
can predict whether or not we will
successfully overcome challenges and how
we strategize in order to set and meet
goals and in 2020 i learned of dr
balchetta's book which was written for
the general public entitled clearer
closer better how successful people see
the world and i read both the hard copy
of the book and listened to the
audiobook and i absolutely loved the
material as you'll learn directly from
dr balchettas today
how people visualize a problem that is
whether or not they think of a goal or a
problem as residing at the top of a very
steep hill or on the top of a shallower
hill
or whether or not they visualize a goal
or a problem as far off in the distance
or closer to them in the distance
visually in their mind
strongly dictates whether or not they
will arrive at the challenge of meeting
a goal or overcoming a problem with more
energy or less energy indeed it dictates
whether or not they can
push to immediate milestones or whether
or not they will think they have to
overcome the entire task all at once
basically
dr balchettis's work has discovered that
how we visualize a problem or a goal in
our mind
has everything to do with how we lean
into that goal whether or not we think
of it as overwhelming or tractable
whether or not we think that we can
overcome that goal and then it will lead
to yet more possible rewards and goals
or whether or not we feel that we're
going to arrive at the finish line and
then just be overwhelmed with fatigue in
other words how you visualize things in
your mind and when i say visualize i
mean literally how you visualize them as
a visual problem or a visual goal
has everything to do with whether or not
you will be able to meet those goals and
whether or not they will lead to still
greater goals that you will be able to
achieve
today's episode is an especially
important one i believe because you're
going to learn about
quality peer-reviewed science from the
expert in this field of goal-setting
motivation and pursuit and you're also
going to learn an immense number of
practical tools that you can apply
toward your educational goals your
career goals relationship goals goals of
any sort by the end of today's episode
you will be better equipped to set and
achieve your goals dr bauchettis also
shares with us her own experiences of
how to set visualize and achieve goals
and she does that within the context of
her role as a parent as somebody
navigating relationships of various
kinds and a demanding career so again i
think that you'll find the information
today to be both
extremely
academically grounded in terms of
research
extremely practical and realistic in
terms of how you might apply it in your
own life i'm pleased to announce that
the huberman lab podcast is now
partnered with momentous supplements we
partnered with momentous for several
important reasons first of all they ship
internationally because we know that
many of you are located outside of the
united states that's valuable second of
all and perhaps most important the
quality of their supplements is second
to none both in terms of purity and
precision of the amounts of the
ingredients
third we've really emphasized
supplements that are single ingredient
supplements and that are supplied in
dosages that allow you to build a
supplementation protocol
that's optimized for cost that's
optimized for effectiveness and that you
can add things and remove things from
your protocol in a way that's really
systematic and scientific this is really
hard to do if you're taking blends of
different supplements or if the dosages
are such that you can't titrate or that
is adjust the dosages of a given
supplement so by using single ingredient
supplements you can really build out the
supplement kit that's ideal for you and
your specific needs if you'd like to see
the supplements that we've partnered
with momentous on you can go to
livemomentus.com
huberman there you'll see those
supplements and just keep in mind that
we are constantly expanding the library
of supplements available through
momentous on a regular basis again
that's livemomentus.com
huberman before we begin i'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
stanford it is however part of my desire
and effort to bring zero cost to
consumer information about science and
science-related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme i'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is thesis
thesis makes custom nootropics and as
some of you have probably heard me say
before i'm not a fan of the word
nootropics because nootropics means
smart drugs and frankly as a
neuroscientist the notion of a smart
drug is somewhat ridiculous why well it
turns out that we have neural circuits
in our brain that get engaged for
creativity and yet other neural circuits
that are engaged for focus and still
other neural circuits that are engaged
for task switching so the notion of a
smart drug or a drug that can induce
smartness if you will
is simply not grounded in science well
thesis understands this and has
developed custom nootropics that are
tailored to the specific types of
cognitive demands or physical demands
that you might be facing if you go to
thesis website you can take a quiz and
from that they'll give you a sample of
different nootropics that you can try so
that you can create a customized kit of
nootropics for your specific needs to
get your own personalized nootropic
starter kit just go online to
takethesis.com huberman take that
three-minute quiz and thesis will send
you four different formulas to try in
your first month that's take thesis.com
huberman and use the code huberman at
checkout to get 10 off your first box
today's episode is also brought to us by
levels levels is what's called a
continuous glucose monitor some of you
may have heard of these before others of
you perhaps have not basically it's a
small device that you wear in the back
your arm it's an app that you install on
your phone and whether or not you are
fasting or you just ate or you ate
several hours ago you can get a
real-time measurement of your blood
glucose which turns out to be extremely
informative i first started using the
levels continuous glucose monitor about
a year ago and it's taught me so much
about how i respond to specific foods in
terms of blood sugar spikes how i
respond to exercise even the sauna it
turns out can modulate my blood glucose
levels and your blood glucose levels in
very interesting ways so all of that is
translated into a huge number of very
directed changes that i've made in terms
of what i eat when i eat and how i
schedule exercise relative to eating and
sleep etc if you're interested in trying
the levels continuous glucose monitor
yourself you can simply go to levels dot
link slash hubermann that's levels dot
link slash hubermann today's episode is
also brought to us by roca roca makes
eyeglasses and sunglasses that are of
the absolute highest quality and they
also have some unique characteristics
the company was founded by two all
american swimmers from stanford and
everything about roka eyeglasses and
sunglasses were designed with
performance in mind roka eyeglasses and
sunglasses can be worn while running or
cycling if you get sweaty they won't
fall off your face and they're extremely
lightweight in fact most of the time i
can't even remember that i'm wearing
them i wear roka eyeglasses when i read
at night so i wear their readers and i
wear sunglasses at various times
throughout the day the great thing about
roka eyeglasses and sunglasses is that
even though they were designed for
athletic performance they have a
terrific aesthetic so unlike a lot of
so-called performance glasses that make
people look like cyborgs in my opinion
eyeglasses and sunglasses are the sort
that you could wear out to dinner that
you could wear to work they have a
terrific aesthetic if you'd like to try
roka eyeglasses or sunglasses you can go
to roca that's roka.com and enter the
code huberman to save 20 off your first
order again that's roca roka.com and
enter the code huberman at checkout and
now for my discussion with dr emily
balchettas well thanks for being here
it's my pleasure yeah i've been looking
forward to this for a long time uh
because as a vision scientist
uh who is also very interested in real
life tools and goal setting and
motivation your work lands squarely in
the middle of those interests
so just to kick things off
you could tell us just a little bit
about the relationship between
perception
and in particular how we see the world
and
goal setting and goal retrieval
it's a vast landscape but you're the
expert so i'll turn that over to you and
then uh as time goes on uh i may have
some additional questions as it relates
to different kinds of vision but what's
the deal with vision and motivation how
do those two things link up totally i
mean
like when we when psychologists ask
people like how are you what are you
doing to help make progress on your
goals they say all kinds of things a
couple things always pop to the top
which is you know try to shock myself in
encouraging ways you know self self pep
talks or i remind myself of how
important it is to to do this job or you
know i'll put up post-it notes around uh
to like constantly be nagging me about
what i need to do so those are common
tactics that people use what we'll
notice is that those are really
effortful having to constantly remind
yourself having to constantly talk to
yourself having to create those post-it
notes remember to look at them all of
that takes a lot of time and effort and
commitment and so what a surprise that
people burn out right it's exciting to
work on a goal when you've when you
first set it you might make some initial
progress but then eventually we get
you know not even to the halfway point
but before
things get real things are challenging
and we fall by the wayside and that's i
think because those tactics that are our
go-to strategies
are themselves a goal to maintain so
it's like you know double-sided we're
putting so much on ourselves to try to
advance the thing that we originally set
out to accomplish so then i you know
with my team i was trying to think of
like well what are strategies that don't
require as much effort that we can
automate that we can take advantage of
what's already happening within
ourselves within our body within our
mind
that might overcome one of those
challenges that'll be easier more
automated and that's when we started to
land on the idea of vision right we look
at the world without even thinking of it
for those of us that are sighted
and and we thought you know what there
are there are strategies that we can use
to look at the world in a different way
and that we can automate that might help
us to overcome some obstacles to make
progress on our goals to maybe literally
see opportunities that we hadn't been
able to see before so we started playing
around with the idea of visual illusions
to see
like do people even know that there's
other ways of seeing things around them
can we tweak that is there room for
intervention can we encourage people
um to take a new way of looking to to
see things that they hadn't seen before
and that's what really opened us up to
trying to look at that intersection
between
vision science and motivation science
it's great and
i always say and here i'm strongly
biased as a vision scientist that you
know vision is the dominant sense by
which we navigate the world and survive
i love this idea of re real world real
time access to vision and i'm certainly
familiar with how goal setting or or
post-its and you know and magnets on
refrigerators can have an immediate
impact but then over time they become so
part of the visual landscape that you
overlook them and we know as vision
scientists if something is stably in
your environment eventually you're blind
to it so that makes good sense so
you've published a number of studies in
this area but um maybe you could
highlight some of the more
what you would consider
important findings in the area of how
people can
adjust their vision in order to meet
goals more quickly and more efficiently
and perhaps also how we come
we all arrive at goals
with different visual perceptions and
that in some way may divide us into
highly motivated and less motivated
people in other words what's the link
between vision and motivation and how
can we leverage that in order to better
reach our goals totally so you know we
started thinking about what are the
goals that are most important to people
that they struggle with the most
so
we asked hundreds thousands of people
what their new year's resolutions are we
look to all the other polls that do the
same kind of work and regardless of
where you look or who you ask or when
you ask it people's number one goal is
something related to their health right
to to lose weight to exercise more to to
get out get more steps for mental
well-being physical well-being
and and that's like the number one goal
every january 1st so if if we were able
to accomplish that goal you'd think it
would drop a little bit in the rankings
but it doesn't because it's really hard
so we thought i wonder if there's a way
for us to make some progress on that on
helping people to exercise better more
often stick to it longer and make some
progress there
we know diets don't work and why why
don't diets work for the same reason
that that self-talk doesn't work is that
you know we go in it full bore hardcore
uh and it requires a major commitment
and effort to a lifestyle change so
again we were looking for something that
might be easier than that that could
produce big big payoff right that's
that's the golden ticket is something
that requires less effort for a bigger
payoff
so one of the first things that i did
was um go over to brooklyn to this old
armory building it you know used to
be a military armory space yeah i know
that building yeah it's a beautiful
building now that houses a lot of
businesses right with plants on the
walls yeah there's businesses there's a
couple armories all around um the the
boroughs here around new york city and
one and the one in brooklyn in
particular is now ymca right so it's a
family ymca that's within a beautiful
old red brick building that used to be a
military establishment long long ago
and what's really cool is that you know
one winter after afternoon you know
somebody had invited me a physical
therapist said hey you should come out
and check out what's happening here with
your interest in exercise and trying to
find new ways of helping people new
tactics that they can add to their tool
belt
i think you're going to find some
interesting people that are working out
there so i showed up i look around you
know there's families there's new moms
there's kids that are you know mom's
trying to get kids to burn off some
winter you know energy that they have
there's people that look like they're
just there for their you know every
couple of days going out for a run
there's some people that look like
they're training with a team and that's
who this physical therapist introduced
introduced me to is that was the coach
of this team
there's a bunch of people that were
sitting down on the ground and i would
be hard-pressed to know who's the high
school student that's in this group and
then who as it turns out are some of the
fastest runners in the world like you
know one of the people that was in the
the last olympics before i showed up won
the gold medal for the 400 meter and and
from the looks of them i mean of course
their bodies are in better shape than
mine but there's nothing so potential of
course they're not wearing their medals
there's nothing pretentious about how
they're walking around or anything like
that that would lead me to know like
this person's amazing and they probably
have some insight that i don't have
so once i got introduced to them and
knew who are these people that were part
of this
pretty elite training team that happened
to work out at this family gym
uh i had the chance to talk with them
about what strategies do you use
now i am not an elite runner and having
recently had a baby i'm not really a
runner right now at all but i thought
when these people
are running i bet they are like hyper
aware of everything that's going on in
their surroundings where are they
relative to the competition what's
happening in their peripheral vision
what's going on on the side who's behind
them who's in front of them they
probably have this like master sense
this master visual plan at any point in
time and that's what probably makes them
elite
so when i started asking them
is that the case do you do you really
pay attention to what's in your
surroundings what's behind you what's on
the side they said no like all of them
said no
and sometimes when i do do that it's a
mistake it doesn't work for me so that
was surprising it totally went against
my intuition about what they do that
likely contributes to their success
what they said instead was that they are
hyper focused they assume this narrowed
focus of attention almost like a
spotlight is shining on a target now
when they're running a short distance at
target might literally be the finish
line the line that they're trying to
cross if it's a longer distance they set
sub goals like you know the person the
shorts on the person up ahead that
they're trying to beat or they choose
some sort of stable landmark like a sign
that that they would pass by
and like a spotlight is shining just on
that or like they have blinders on the
sides of their face that's all they're
paying attention to
it's really narrowed scope of attention
and that was a strategy that they that
all of these elite athletes said that
they used and those that were better
rather than um you know then slower were
ones that used it more and i thought oh
that's something we can play with right
like they are elite and they are
accomplished but that visual strategy
isn't necessarily something that you
have to be in the perfect physical
condition to be able to adopt and so i
wonder can that help the rest of us who
aren't competing for an olympic gold and
who have no chance of ever getting one
but who want to exercise better have a
better have a better time doing it and
maintain a commitment to that exercise
goal that they might have that they
might otherwise you know by february or
march be giving up on
if they had said it at the beginning of
january so that's really where the work
started was you know what you might call
like focus groups or case studies of
these incredible athletes
and um and then we did other studies
looking at you know you know people who
aren't olympic athletes but who are
competitive new york road runners
runners and how are they running in
races and what we found is that those
people have better pace faster pace
better time
they use that narrowed strategy more
often than this more expansive or you
know open scope of attention and there
seem to be a correlation between that
better performance among a wider swath
of hundreds of of runners who are doing
it competitively but still you know
could be like the person that you're
sitting next to in the office
or yourself right and the more often
that they did it the and the more um
consistently they had adopted that that
technique of the narrowed focus of
attention it seemed that they were doing
better in their runs
so then we started thinking like okay
what about people who who aren't
competitive runners what about like my
mom can can she do that or me when i'm
trying to get back on the bandwagon and
exercise more is this a tactic we can
teach people the answer is yes you can
tell people about what these olympic
athletes are doing you can tell them
about what the new york road runners
runners are doing
and just using the same language that i
just use with you right imagine that
there's a spotlight shining just on a
target choose choose something up ahead
the stop sign two blocks up that you can
you can just see
and you know imagine that you you have
blinders on so that you're not really
paying attention to the people that are
passing by or the buildings or the
garbage cans or the or the trucks that
are on the road
you know tune those out and focus in on
that target until you hit it and then
choose another one right sort of
recalibrate choose the next goal
and so we would test like can people do
that
i mean if you're listening right now you
probably are imagining that experience
too and the answer is yes like i can
imagine that i know what those words
mean and i can do that and our work
found that too that people can do that
we have them say out loud what is it
that's captured your attention
and of course sometimes something in the
periphery like movement captures our
gaze and we're pulled there for for an
instant but then we can refocus up again
and adopt that narrowed attention
now one of the first studies that we did
was was teach that strategy and
juxtapose or compare it against a group
that we said just look around naturally
you know you might see that finish line
up ahead and there's things on the
periphery whatever your eyes want to do
whatever you think is going to work best
feel free to do that and tell us what
you're looking at
then we gave them a finish line we
created sort of you know an exercise
that's moderately challenging
but possible we put ankle weights on
that that accounted for about 15 of
their body weight told them to lift
their knees up sort of high stepping to
a finish line so this would be
challenging
for them to do
but we said you know it's an indicator
of overall health and fitness
some of these people had narrowed their
focus of attention and some were just
looking more expansively or naturally
and what we found is that those people
that we trained just everyday normal
people doing this this moderately
challenging exercise they were able to
move 27 faster they could do the
exercise more quickly and they said it
hurt 17
less
the exercise was exactly the same for
all the people we set we set the weight
we set the distance it was in you know
our lab space so it was a con
constrained environment everybody was in
the same sort of circumstance but yet
their experience was really different we
helped them to move faster burn calories
at a higher rate right exercise more
efficiently the amount of time they put
in is going to produce a better uh
physical outcome
and it also it didn't hurt them right
they're saying it doesn't hurt as much
so we were really excited about that
right because it meant that this
strategy we could use it on people who
are not elite athletes it could be
easily adopted a quick training session
we can teach people to look at the world
in a different way again this narrowed
attention was different than whatever
they do naturally the comparison group
um but it had a big outcome it had a big
difference on the way that they were
engaged in the exercise that was like
some of the first work that we did and
then since then we've done you know
dozens more studies to look at well what
happens at that and and what else can we
do with playing around with this yeah
those are impressive differences uh as a
consequence of narrowing visual
attention a couple questions about the
actual practice of narrowing attention
is there any indication of whether or
not subjects um are constantly updating
their visual attention so for instance
if let's say the goal line is
uh in view literally from the beginning
i can imagine just holding visual
attention on the on the goal line but um
if it's a
oval track or it's a trajectory along a
trail or through a city how often do you
think they are updating their um
their visual aperture and setting a
visual goal
and i could imagine that there's some
energetic expense to that so that um
meaning how you know you wouldn't want
to do every crack on the sidewalk unless
those cracks on the sidewalk were very
far apart right because i think at some
point that itself would be exhausting
um so is there
uh an optimal strategy or a semi-optimal
strategy
yeah so you know those olympic athletes
that we that we started by interviewing
they tended to be sprinters they were
more often sprinters short distance
printers so when they said like yes i
narrow in more than i assume an
expansive focus that's because they're
not going that far right they have to do
it as fast as humanly possible but
they're not going that far
and so we started asking that question
too about like well wouldn't that be
tiring and the answer is yes so when we
start to look at well people who aren't
sprinters who are accomplished but who
are more long-distance runners that's
what we find that they do is that they
um you know they're using that narrowed
attention strategy strategically
and it increases in use they use it more
often as the race progresses and they
really start to do this you know major
switch
about the halfway point of say like a 10
kilometer run so people who are seasoned
runners they really start making a
switch with what they're looking at
about halfway through
and that's where they more often more
frequently and are more intentionally
adopting a narrowed focus of attention
when they're in the last couple miles of
a run when maybe their resources are
starting to get more thin maybe their
motivation is starting to fade
that tipping point in the middle is with
any kind of goal where people struggle
the most
uh and that's when they're like doubling
down on a strategy that they know to be
effective
so
you know at first longer distance
runners are not using that narrowed
strategy they're they're looking more
expansively um because i think that that
well first of all distraction is a thing
it's useful not necessarily that they're
distracting themselves because people
are still trying to hold pace
and jostle among probably a more
concentrated group of runners
but it is a strategy that they use and
then sort of wean off of
as the race goes through and it's
particularly effective when we're
looking for that last push right the
last push to get over the finish line
when like you might be literally neck
and neck with somebody that you're
you're trying to to just be out
or when you're most tired but you know
like that last push you don't want to
you don't want to drop off um and you
know you want to when you want to push
through hard through that finish line
that's when people are using it at its
peak level of intensity i see yeah i
to me this makes total sense why it
would work
without going down the
rabbit hole of visual neuroscience of
something for another time when we do
these virgins eye movements when we
bring our eyes to a visual target it's
clear that some of the brain stem
circuitry for alertness
gets uh engaged uh to a greater degree
the other thing is that we know that
when we focus on an object that the
the optics of the eye change and and
narrow the visual field so that brings
about this is a very detailed question
but i'm sure the audience is is
wondering if let's say i'm focused on a
goal line or or a intermediate goal are
they focusing on a specific point or is
it kind of the entire horizon of that
goal because the finish line is indeed a
line um so and of course this is it's
impossible to know what someone is
actually doing in their mind's eye but
how do people report this do they see it
literally as a spotlight and if so how
broad is that spot
yeah so you know what is the the the
length of of their aperture rather than
the maybe the diameter or the sphere
sphere size of it um you know in our
interviews with people our sort of focus
group studies um
it seems like it's more like a a
circular point and that's in fact what
we're teaching people what we're
training them to do so rather than going
broadly looking across a line from left
to right we are encouraging them to like
imagine a circle of light that's shining
on some target now of course a finish
line is a line but if they're staying in
their lane if they're on a track right
you can imagine that there is that there
is a circle shining just on where in
their lane they'll cross that finish
line or if it's a stop sign you can
imagine a circle of light illuminating
that so that's what we're teaching
people to use and that's what seems to
be effective to maintain that focus
rather than sort of being pulled to
engage with peripheral vision
and there's some amazing people
some runners in history like joan benoit
samuelson she's one of the first uh
female marathon competitors who has won
multiple marathons she's canadian i
think she's one
feel free to correct me like 10
marathons in her life uh and she talks
about sort of not assuming this like
this wide but
um
but narrow
wide but not deep or tall
attentional focus she talks about like
finding the shorts on somebody ahead of
me and focusing on on those shorts until
she passes them and then resetting that
goal so in you know her interviews that
she's done with runners magazines she
talks about it in terms of this the
circle of attention
i think i've experienced this a little
bit um
because we're visiting new york now to
do this interview and uh runners here
seem more competitive the recreational
runners here seem more competitive
walk people walking on the street seem
competitive if you're walking at near
pace to somebody they'll quickly speed
up if you speed up they'll speed up yeah
i think there's been some studies about
walking speed in different cities and
new york ranks among the fastest walkers
around i won't mention the slowest
walking cities because we don't want to
cast any judgments but um
fascinating uh and again makes total
sense based on the way the the visual
system measures both space and time
something maybe we'll get into a little
bit later but i'm curious
whether or not
this the whole thing works in reverse as
well meaning
uh
do
people who
are very motivated to exercise
do they think this way naturally
people who are averse to exercise or who
find it hard to get motivated to
exercise
do they
view the world differently literally
yeah i have so much that i can say about
this um so
if you'll humor me i'll give you a
couple different uh stories about how we
can answer that so you don't have to do
a deep dive into vision science which of
course you are capable of doing um
but but what i can share with you is
some like animal studies where this work
kind of first started
this was in the 1940s 1950s rat labs
mice labs and they were looking you know
those were the first models of of um of
human behavior that people were trying
to understand motivation motivation
science within
so they would you know deprive these
poor rats and mice of food or water so
that they were motivated to to get it
they were hungry and they were thirsty
and they had practice running a maze so
they knew where they could find that
food or water or whatever that they were
looking for
and what these researchers were studying
was the pace of of movement through the
maze
so as these
as the rats were like going through the
maze they found that even though these
rats were hungry and they're having to
expend limited caloric uh
energy
to make it to the finish line they
actually ran faster the closer they got
to that finish line so once that finish
line became
nearer to them
they actually you know use their
resources probably you know
sub-optimally to make sure that they
cross the finish line and got their
reward
so that was like some of the first early
work that that was showing that you know
proximity to a goal increases the
investment in in resources that people
that animals
use to meet that goal
even when they don't have that much to
spare and with the mice the same kind of
thing you know they were they actually
had these little harnesses on them
they're looking at how hard did the mice
pull
to try to make it to the food or the
water that they were trying to get and
same deal the closer they got to to
getting their reward the harder they
were pulling even though they didn't
have that that much energy to spare and
they had already used some up getting to
that finish line
so that was that was that early animal
research from the 1940s 1950s then
spurred a whole wave of work in humans
do humans do the same thing you know
even when they're tired but they can
they can see or they can feel that their
goal is close do they double down and
work even harder to cross that finish
line either like a literal finish line
if we're talking about exercise or a
metaphorical finish line if we're
talking about any other kind of goal
that people might have and the answer is
yes they called that the goal gradient
hypothesis the closer you get to the
goal
generally the harder people and animals
work to finish that goal
that's what led us then to think okay
you know those rats those mice those
people are seeing the finish line right
and it's when they're maybe seeing that
finish line seeing that reward seeing
the goal they're hoping to accomplish
that is what's leading them to you know
try harder to invest more so that they
can finish it off
what if we induce that illusion of
proximity what if we can induce a visual
illusion a visual experience
um that approximates what the
real rats and mice were were actually
experiencing as they got closer
so
that is what is happening that's what's
happening visually when we create that
narrowed focus of attention when we tell
people imagine there's a spotlight on
the shorts of the person up ahead or the
stop sign that you're seeing it induces
an illusion of proximity that then is
responsible for people trying harder
walking faster feeling that it defied
their expectations and that it wasn't as
bad as they thought it would be
so we do things like measure like
measure their visual experience how far
away is that finish line of course we
can ask them to report in feet how many
feet is it
but that's challenging right like nobody
really knows what what three feet versus
four feet really looks like but but they
do so we can ask them how many feet it
is we also use these other measures of
visual matching measures to know like
that distance at the finish line looks
about as far away as as as this other
target they're matching up their visual
experiences so what we know is that
inducing that narrowed focus of
attention is creating an illusion of
proximity that goal looks closer to them
and then there's all kinds of downstream
motivational psychological effects that
happen from feeling like you're closer
by
by by visually misperceiving that space
it can have a really positive
consequence so your first question was
you know which way does it go does it go
both ways that people who are better
runners like happen to do this thing yes
some of our research shows that that if
they you know for whatever reason
happened upon this strategy and continue
to practice it they tend to be the
better runners
but we also know from our experiments in
the lab where we take people who don't
know about these strategies and by a
flip of the coin we randomly assign them
to either learn the strategy and use it
or do whatever comes naturally to them
we can create that illusion of proximity
that has a direct and causal impact on
improving the performance
when they're exercising so yes it goes
both ways but you can also teach
yourself that you don't have to just
rely on on luck luck of the draw for
being a person who happens to be better
at exercising or whose eyes happen to do
this on their own before we continue
with today's discussion we're going to
take a brief pause to acknowledge our
sponsor athletic greens also called ag-1
i started taking athletic greens way
back in 2012 so i'm delighted that
they've been a sponsor of this podcast
athletic greens contains vitamins
minerals probiotics digestive enzymes
and adaptogens so it's got a lot of
things in there that's actually the
reason i started taking it and the
reason i still take it once or twice a
day essentially covers all my
nutritional bases and the probiotics in
particular are important to me because
of the critical importance of what's
called the gut brain axis that is
neurons and other cell types in the gut
in the digestive tract that communicate
with the brain and the brain back to the
digestive tract in order to control
things like mood immune function hormone
function and on and on whenever somebody
has asked me what's the one supplement
they should take i always answer
athletic greens i gave that answer long
before i ever had this podcast and it's
the answer i still give now for all the
reasons that i detailed just a moment
ago if you'd like to try athletic greens
you can go to athleticgreens.com
huberman to claim a special offer
they'll give you five free travel packs
that make it really easy to mix up
athletic greens while you're on the road
plus a year's supply of vitamin d3 k2
which are also very important for a huge
number of bodily factors and brain
factors that impact your immediate and
long-term health again that's
athleticgreens.com huberman to claim
that special offer the most pressing
question i have in my mind is can
we i
all of us use this strategy to make the
starting line a goal point because for a
lot of people it's not about going from
start to finish it's about getting to
start
and you know i would say
here i'm
estimating but 15 of the content on
social media is about motivation and how
to get motivated to do things um
neurochemicals like
dopamine of course being at the heart of
motivation i in my mind i'm making
strong links between some of these
visual aperture effects and goal lines
and dopamine uh
that we could also dive into but
the simple question is can i use this
finish line strategy to make the start
line
a goal and get my system more engaged or
motivated and is there any physiology or
physiological changes i should say to
reflect the idea that maybe just
visually focusing on the start line
would actually get me
more excited as opposed to make me less
excited to engage in effort
there's certainly vision science that's
tied up in that
very first stage of of goal setting like
identifying what that goal is in the
first place and taking those first steps
a lot of people's go-to strategies that
involve vision are our vision boards or
dream boards or you know post-it notes
right they're creating some sort of
visual representation of what it is that
they want to accomplish
where is it that i want to be in five
years 10 days 10 years whatever whatever
that timeline is that they're working
under the idea of vision boards or dream
boards is that you you know almost like
a scrapbook collect visual icons that
reflect where you want to be to motivate
yourself it's a really common tactic
that people use
and it's not bad to do that right for
some people just even knowing what they
want in life is a major accomplishment
defining the goal can be really
challenging for people and that's a
strategy that works and involves our
visual experience right it's not just
people aren't saying like why don't you
just sit around and imagine what you
want your life to be like in 10 years
the strategy that people are suggesting
is like no cut out the pictures put it
on a board and stick it by your bathroom
mirror so you see it every day we'll
make a list make a list people are big
on these lists i have a lot of friends
like have you made your list yeah like
the list of things that you insist on
having in the context of
fitness relationship job et cetera et
cetera this seems more and more common
yeah totally and the idea like write it
down right they're telling you write it
down like or or
create a visual manifestation of it
um and so yeah that that's effective
for identifying what you want but it may
not actually be effective for helping
you to meet the goal to get the job done
so colleagues of mine at new york
university have probed why why is that
why is just you know thinking about what
you want in your life and and sort of
putting yourself vicariously into those
shoes imagining what my life will be
like if i can accomplish everything on
this list
why doesn't that well first of all does
it work the answer is no and why does it
not work
because what happens these colleagues
gabrielle oatenjen and her and her
research team have found
is that
you know going through and dreaming
about or
or visualizing how great my life will be
when i get x y and z done
um that is that is like a goal
satisfied
i have identified what it is that i want
i have experienced it even if just in an
imaginary way i've had that positive
experience of of thinking about what how
great my life is going to be when i get
this thing done and they start to sort
of rest on their laurels she's actually
measured systolic blood pressure and
heart rate and they found that people
who do that who go through that
experience of visualizing how great my
life will be when i get x y and z done
their their systolic blood pressure the
bottom number on your blood pressure
reading
decreases
okay now i'm all about finding ways to
relax especially in new york right
you're constantly living at a high level
of stimulation and so like cool great so
maybe i should just like think about how
awesome my life will be when i get my
bucket my bucket list done
but motivation scientists know that
systolic blood pressure is actually an
indicator of our body's readiness to get
up and act to do something now that can
be the going out for a walk going out
for a run hitting the gym it can also be
things like doing math problems right
even if it's something that's just
mental systolic blood pressure actually
goes up in anticipation of your body or
your mind needing to do something taking
the first steps on a goal
so then it is it helps us to understand
of like okay if i've just created this
dream board this vision board and put
myself psychologically in that space of
a goal satisfied why is it bad that
blood pressure goes down because it
means your body is chilling out it's
like all right cool i just accomplished
something pretty major
i actually now don't have the
physiological resources at the ready to
take the first step right now to do
something about that
so
so that was a pretty monumental um
finding for motivation scientists to
understand that like creating these
dream boards these vision boards or
to-do lists might actually backfire
because it in and of itself is the
creation of a goal and the satisfaction
of the goal and then people
understandably give themselves some time
to just enjoy that positive experience
so much for the secret
yeah exactly
exactly i guess now the secret folks
will come after me pitchforks i try to
never say the name right i'm not afraid
to say the name i mean i i imagine that
certain strategies might work for other
people but i
everything you're saying again is
consistent what we know about the
physiology of dopamine circuits for
motivation i have a good friend who
perhaps incidentally perhaps not is a
cardiologist
at a major university said that one of
the major errors that people make with
book writing and completion is they will
tell people they're going to write a
book and people will say oh you
definitely should write a book
everyone's going to love your book and
they never end up writing it and his
theory is that they get so much
dopamine reward from that immediate
feedback with all the protection of
never having the book criticized that
they never write the book i'm sure there
are exceptions to this but um i guess it
raises the question what's the better
strategy yeah so i'm not saying that
people who enjoy
a dream board creation should stop what
they're doing that's not the take-home
message here right bored
oh definitely not that no there's enough
anxiety and fear in the world we don't
need to encourage more of it
um but the process of goal setting
shouldn't stop with articulating what
the goal is
so
at that same point that we're trying to
figure out what do we want to do what
what is my vision for the future
in those planning sessions we need to
simultaneously think about a couple
other things
one
is
how are we going to get there so take it
out of the abstract take it out of this
idyllic visual iconography and start
thinking about the practical day-to-day
we need to break it down into more
manageable goals not just my 10-year
plan for myself but my two-week plan
what what can i accomplish in the next
two weeks and the two weeks after that's
gonna set me on the right trajectory
that's probably not surprising to
anybody who's been thinking about how do
i set goals better
you know plan plan big picture think big
picture abstractly but then also break
it down more concretely that's probably
not surprising but it's an important
aspect of the goal setting process
then again gabrielle odenjen in my
department has identified a third often
overlooked or under appreciated stage
that has to happen
at that goal in the goal-setting process
and that's thinking about the obstacles
that stand in your way of success
and that will actually help improve
motivation in the long run
and sometimes people think that that
like is counter-intuitive you're saying
like for if i want to increase my
motivation have more motivation than i
need to think about how hard it's going
to be all the ways that i'm going to
fail how is that going to like jazz me
up how is that going to help me get
through when i actually you know
when when things get hard
but it does because it's like coming up
with a plan b a plan c plan d in advance
of actually experiencing that
if you were on a boat and the boat
started to sink that's not the time you
want to start looking for life jackets
you already want to know where one is so
you can go to it right away and it's the
same thing with goal setting is that you
want to know what am i working towards
how i'm going to get there and if i
experience this obstacle
here's what i'm going to do about it you
may never experience that obstacle but
if you do you're probably going to be
shy on time thin on resources maybe
experiencing an anxiety that hijacks
your brain so you're not functioning at
that optimal level of judgment and
decision making
you want to already have like the snap
next step in place so you can just hop
to it right we're not going to do our
best thinking when we're in crisis mode
um but we don't have to if we have used
if we have already used our resources in
advance to come up with that plan b or
that plan c
michael phelps like incredible athlete
right this is something that he and his
coach have routinely incorporated into
their uh into their training so i love
this story that like back in 2008 he was
you know hot hot for the first time on
the international stage it was the
beijing olympics michael phelps was on
the brink of doing something that no one
else in the history of the olympic games
has ever done which is win eight gold
medals in a single olympiad
at the time of this story he had already
won seven and he had just the 200 fly in
front of him before he could do what no
one else has ever done when the eighth
gold medal
and like the fly is his thing right this
should have been this should have been
easy like a no-brainer he's going to win
this he's going to break olympic history
as soon as he dove into the pool his
goggles started to leak
and by the time he had done three
lengths of the pool he just had to flip
around and come back to the to the
starting line slash finish line back to
the edge um by the time that happened
his goggles were completely filled with
water and he was swimming blind
i would have panicked i would have sunk
to the bottom of the pool i wouldn't
have been in the pool to be honest like
i'm not a swimmer definitely not going
to be in the olympics but
but for him he didn't it wasn't a moment
of panic like it probably would have
been for nearly every other person in
that situation
because he had foreshadowed that kind of
possible failure he had imagined that
obstacle hitting him in advance and not
even just imagined it but practiced it
what will we do he routinely practiced
swimming with his goggles not fully
secured on his face his coach
notoriously would uh rip the goggles off
of his head smash him on the ground for
maybe dramatic effect or something so
that he didn't even have any goggles
possible to grab as he's as he's in
practice
so because he had foreshadowed that
possibility and the solution
if my goggles start to leak then i will
do
in his case start counting my strokes
then i'll make it through he knew
exactly how many strokes it would take
from him to get from one end of the pool
to the other he started counting his
strokes he won that he won that race the
200 fly he won his eighth gold medal and
he'd go on to win 15 more in his career
so we might not all be swimmers we might
not all aspire to olympic level
performance but i love that example
because i think it it helps sort of
demystify or give us an alternative
perspective on the importance
and the motivational reasons why
thinking about obstacles in advance
thinking about the ways the two three
four ways that your plan might go awry
is actually effective at helping us
overcome the obstacle that might
otherwise lead us to throw in the towel
that's a beautiful example
i'm going to springboard off that
example to ask a question that
has also been on my mind which is
is there really anything special about
vision because in the example you just
gave it was indeed vision that michael
phelps was deprived of and it was
counting strokes
counting is another form of incremental
measurement in the nervous system
obviously
[Music]
there are others it could be the
sensation of the of the hands smacking
the water or breaking the surface of the
water so
there are any number of different
variables or metrics that one could use
i could imagine that setting out on
a
let's say a three mile run which for me
is a decent distance run it's one i do a
few times a week i'm also not a runner
but i try and complete some runs a few
times a week at very slow pace just for
my health
i could count every step
that would be kind of exhausting
but if i knew that three miles was
i'm gonna estimate here i don't know a
couple thousand steps
i could count backward i could count
forward i count every 10.
um
i confess i spend every morning trying
to find sunlight to get sun in my eyes
to set my circadian rhythm and i do 100
jumping jacks so i'm the
guy that people are looking at strange
on the street but sometimes they count
every 10 sometimes they count backwards
sometimes i count forward
is there any indication that it matters
or is it simply that we attach some sort
of meaning to that increment
and
the mode of reaching that increment
because it does seem like there's
something special about vision we could
maybe dive into a little bit more why
that is but at a very basic level
how broadly or fo or finally should one
set the increments and does it matter if
you're counting steps or counting
strokes if you're
maybe it's every other song you're going
to listen to an entire album
that's something that i don't know if
people do anymore or you're going to
listen to a whole playlist and then
listen to it again and you're going to
run as long as the playlist
is completed twice
you can obviously see what i'm getting
at but i know people are going to want
to implement these tools and i have to
guess that the nervous system is is
somewhat
indiscriminate when it comes to these
things but that there might also be some
specificity
i think vision is special and i think
you do too
uh so
and for a variety of reasons when you
start you can really nerd out on how
cool the brain is and how cool vision is
within the brain and when you do then
you start to find some things that make
vision unique right more more real
estate more neurological cortex
real estate is taken up by the visual
sense than any other sense more than
taste touch
smell
right
vision gets more real estate gets more
neurological processing space than any
other sense why is that well because
evolution has led us to prioritize that
visual the visual experience
there's some cool illusions where like
maybe somebody's mouth is doing
something different than what you're
hearing when people sort of create these
like you know weird tricks that might go
on youtube and go viral um and people
are trying to figure out what did i hear
what did i see his mouth doing and what
comes up is that people people
prioritize what they see over what
they're hearing when the two are
incompatible or kind of like out of sync
every time yeah every time right if you
have to bet on it bet on bet on what it
is that you're looking at rather than
what you're seeing
and why is that well i guess a couple
other things too right like we can see
super far you can see like a flickering
candle on our horizon if it was a
totally you know clear sky
um several miles away you can see the
international space station floating up
in the in the night sky right like
hundreds of miles away our eyes are
amazing
and um and we prioritize what we see
that and i think that's because we never
we rarely get the experience of having
our visual experience second guessed you
know oftentimes we're having a
conversation maybe in a loud restaurant
and we know that we didn't hear the
person right and so we say like oh did
you say that or like oh i thought you
said this and they're like no i didn't
say that right so
people will correct us when our ears get
it wrong
or we're tasting something amazing and
we can't quite figure out what spices
were in here and so we know that our
tongue isn't quite picking up the
the taste the right way and that's why
we read the menu to see what are the
ingredients or we asked the chef like
what did you put in this it tastes
amazing
so we know that our tongue is getting it
wrong or you might be touching something
and you look at the tag to see what sort
of textile was used in this really
amazing piece of clothing that you're
looking to buy so we know that our sense
of touch isn't quite getting it right
but rarely do we have that experience of
having our eyes get updated where we're
looking at something i think i'm looking
at my mom oh no actually it was actually
my husband like okay like that never
happens right that we have gotten vision
as wrong as we might get any other thing
that that we're experiencing through any
other sense
we trust our visual experience we have
sort of a naive realism that what we see
reflects the world the way it actually
is
because it's never really fully tested
we'd never get the input or the feedback
that you've seen something wrong
until a visual illusion pops up on
social media right like the dress
example or the last week or so there's
been that horse seal line drawing that's
been all over social media too what do
you see i see a horse someone says i see
a seal and then like you know chaos
erupts or i thought the dress was blue
and i thought it was
gold i don't remember the options
because i see it as blue so
uh right and it's like dividing up
families and friendships because you've
like seen something that the other
person just literally cannot see and
that's why we love those examples when
they pop up in social media when they do
is because it defies all of our previous
expectations there's a really amazing if
this interests you
there's a really amazing visual artist
anish kapoor who plays with these ideas
too and his installations are are just
fascinating i saw one
at a museum once where
you know walk down this long hall and
it's just a big black rectangle that's
painted on the wall and i was like this
guy's super famous what the hell it's
just a big black rectangle painted on
the wall
what is this about like what hoax you
know this museum paid how much what or
whatever but then as you get closer you
get closer and your eyes start to settle
in and they adapt to the different
visual lighting realize it's not a black
square painted on the wall it's a huge
hole he's carved into the wall and
there's a whole other world that's back
behind there that you can't see right
away until your eyes adapt to the
different lighting conditions beautiful
it's amazing vision scientists i i have
to see where is this exhibit uh it's not
up right now i've i've seen um there was
a retrospective several years ago that
was done uh in sydney um but his work is
all over the place so anish kapoor
definitely definitely worth looking up
because because it um like the dress
example or the horse seal line drawing
or artists like anish kapoor's work
that is a moment that that gives us a
different unexpected insight
about the world that it challenges us to
to see something that we hadn't seen
before or it induces or tricks us into
seeing something that we wouldn't have
otherwise have seen
and so it's those rare moments that i
think are actually really important for
understanding what do our eyes normally
do
because we wouldn't find these examples
so surprising so engaging so shocking if
we had routinely gotten the experience
of realizing we're not seeing the world
the way that it is
so that is why i think vision is is
special
and why it can be thought of as a tool
that we can add to our toolkit uh for
how to better accomplish our goals i'm
not saying that we should just only
focus on imagining the world through a
an attentional spotlight but maybe
that's something that we can employ
strategically on occasion when we think
it's going to best help us when we need
an extra little push to cross that phys
the literal or metaphorical finish line
but it doesn't have to be the only
tactic that we use just like it's not
bad to use vision boards but let's use
something else also it's not it's not
bad to talk to ourselves in encouraging
ways but let's try adding another tool
to our tool belt
in case that's not enough to get the job
done
so i do think that there's great power
in thinking about our visual experience
alongside other tactics that we might
use for meeting our goals and another
one of those tactics might be like the
numerix that you're talking about how
how do i think about my jumping jacks in
terms of groups of 10 or as a set of 100
you do it routinely so you might be able
to set a goal of 100 and have that
sustain you through
number 60 number 70 when maybe it's
starting to get harder but for somebody
who's just starting out and wants to be
able to make it to 100 that's probably
not going to work that's going to be
maybe really that could be quite
challenging for them if it's the first
time that they're trying it and so
instead setting those micro goals of
groups of 10
is going to be useful because as we
start to get to number eight or nine or
number 88 or 89 and it's really getting
hard we need that extra little hedonic
hit of pleasure of accomplishment the
micro dopamine rush that you might get
by hitting another
10 you know another decade milestone
another group of 10 milestone
and once we get that little hit of
pleasure excitement or
self-congratulations
that might be enough to sustain us
through the next
challenging physical obstacle the next
group of 10 that we might experience
so there isn't any like prescription
that i would give and say every person
should decide that 25 jumping jacks is
the goal no we have to be idiosyncratic
and and introspect about where are we at
with this goal this thing that i'm
trying to accomplish and set those goals
realistically but inspirationally as
well we want to set a goal that will
challenge us but isn't impossible
we don't want to set goals that are too
easy because we're not going to trick
ourselves into like feeling so great
about doing one jumping jack okay great
like pretty sure most people if that's a
goal they can do one so are you going to
feel so great when you hit that goal no
because it was too easy you didn't have
any doubt that you could do that one but
what about 25
okay
yeah i might feel pretty good about that
well what about the next group of 25 and
now i'm at 50. those are goals that
might seem just beyond the brink of
what's possible but i will feel good
when i hit that and that's going to give
me the next sort of boost of energy that
i'm going to need to go a little bit
further either that time or the next
time
yeah i think vision is special again i'm
strongly biased here my you know the
reason i
initially learned about your work
was well now you have this amazing book
but at the time there wasn't the book
there were just the scientific papers
and of course upon which the the book
rests
and those papers are really important
but was the relationship between vision
and obviously is our sense of space but
how the sense of space and time are
related and to um make the idea quite
simple for those listening you know when
you you narrow your visual window you're
measuring the time bin also gets smaller
right which makes sense when you hear it
whereas if you take on a huge visual
landscape you're actually carving up
time differently it's sort of like
moving from a slow frame rate to a fine
frame rate you know slow motion camera
is actually taking a lot more snapshots
right so you're measuring distance over
time more finely and so where a strobe
would be the other example which is
strobe is very low frequency so you're
going here here here as opposed to you
know slow motion right strobe gives a
course
uh
course view into the time domain and
high speed photography gives a fine view
in the time domain so i'm almost certain
without any knowledge of underlying
data um i'm but knowledge of the
mechanism then i i'm almost certain
if not certain that
by placing a narrow visual aperture we
change the way we perceive time
now i have a question and i to be honest
i know the answer in advance but i'd
love for you to tell us a bit about
how some of this works still
further in reverse meaning how
unfit people view the world versus how
fit people view the world or how
unmotivated people
visually see the world as opposed to
highly motivated people
you talked about these elite runners you
give them michael phelps example but
maybe you could describe that study i
think it's a particularly important one
mostly because
yes it identifies a perhaps a
physiological or psychological
differences between motivated and
unmotivated or or fit and unfit people
but it also provides a a path to to
remedy that
yeah so
you know there's out of my lab but also
out of several other labs there's been
work looking
looking at that relation between states
of the body and visual experiences um
they haven't necessarily tried to to to
integrate the motivation science element
um to it but they were looking to see
individual experiences change as a
function of different states of our body
so they've looked at people who
experience chronic fatigue um the
elderly people who are overweight
um those that are you know wearing
wearing heavy backpacks and so who are
sort of put into that experience of
being overweight what happens to their
perceptions of the environment well what
they find is that distances look further
to those that are overweight chronically
tired older rather than younger weighted
down with it with extra baggage
um
distances like farther and hills look
steeper
we've we've done some of those studies
too where we try to like give people
more energy or or deprive them of of
energy and see does that change their
their perception of space
and uh we did that by you know sort of a
classic technique of a double-blind
study where the participant doesn't
really know what they're experiencing i
thought you were gonna say a double
espresso
that is also a good psychological
experience to give people
uh yeah so you know a double-blind
experiment where the participant doesn't
really know the the full extent of what
what they're doing or what they're
experiencing and the researcher who's
interacting with them also doesn't you
know they do this a lot in medical
studies you give somebody a drug and you
give somebody a placebo a sugar pill
and then importantly nobody really knows
who's got what until you've analyzed all
the data and the results are revealed
that these are the people that that had
the drug the active agent same idea in
the psychological research in this case
what we did was give people kool-aid to
drink and for some people that kool-aid
was sweetened with sugar an actual
caloric entity it could give them energy
other people drank kool-aid sweetened
with splenda so yeah it's sweet but it
actually doesn't have any caloric value
you're not giving people energy you're
just giving them that that experience
um of of sweetness now some people of
course are really good at identifying
like what's what's real sugar and what
splenda but when you put it in a
kool-aid a pretty noxious powder it
actually masked it for everybody and
nobody had any idea because it tastes
like garbage and everything like garbage
kool-aid i mean i'm sure there are many
people that love kool-aid i guess the
sales of kool-aid will will reveal the
data yeah i grew up in nebraska actually
where kool-aid is from it originated in
nebraska so i do feel like i'm betraying
my roots slightly by um by casting some
shade on kool-aid but
uh but but that's how it worked is that
you know we asked them to guess what
they got we tested them afterwards and
they were wrong so nobody is able to
guess uh with accuracy what was your
drink sweetened with which is important
because they were blind
the way that scientists use it they
didn't know what it was that they were
drinking
we give it um you know we give them
about 10 to 15 minutes for that sugar to
metabolize and we measured
their circulating blood glucose levels
to make sure that we had in fact given
their body a circular circulating
glucose energy that they might use in
the next
activity
and um and the researcher again didn't
know whether they had just served sugar
or splenda then we asked people to
estimate distance so we gave some people
more energy or we kept others sort of at
like whatever their normal level was and
what we found is that those people who
didn't even know it but who had been
given more energy by drinking kool-aid
sweetened with sugar perceived their
space as as more constricted they that
visual illusion of proximity was induced
they felt that their finish line again
in the context of an exercise task was
closer to them
so in just the same way that these other
physiology labs vision science
physiology labs found that people who
are chronically tired who don't have
don't feel like they have as much energy
or those that are physically weighted
down and for whom you know moving within
an environment is more costly um we
could create that experience for people
we did an experimental version of that
that if you have more energy the world
looks
easier the distances to a finish line
don't look as far so that was some of
the experimental evidence that we had um
to show that people states of their body
do impact their visual experience now
i'm a motivation researcher so for me
the big question is well what's the
point of that study then besides just
showing this connection between the body
and the eyes and the visual experience
we think that that's fundamental to one
of the reasons that people experience
difficulty when they're exercising when
it's really harder for your body because
of its physical state
to move within a space
why don't
you might say like why don't they just
go exercise because the world looks
harder to them because that distance
that that they're supposed to walk
because a doctor tells them to or that a
partner encourages them to or a hill
that they should hike up because someone
told them that would be good for their
health it looks more challenging to them
than it does to somebody who isn't who
who isn't who's who's in better physical
health
now if it looks that way if it looks
harder if it feels like it might be
harder
then psychologically we know that it is
when you have set yourself up
psychologically mentally for that kind
of failure experience like i don't know
that i have the resources that to get
this job done this looks really hard
you're already motivationally in a place
for this task to be
closer to impossible for you so to put
it all together then what we know is
that people whose bodies might make it
more challenging for them to exercise
are seeing the world in a more
challenging way and that is having these
downstream motivational and
psychological effects that makes it less
likely for them to try to take on the
task in the first place or to experience
it as harder than than other people
would or do um
is the solution the same however meaning
if these people are taught to adjust
their visual goal line or to set a
visual spotlight on an intermediate goal
can they overcome some of this uh this
challenge that they face simply by
virtue of their skewed perception yes so
in all of the studies that we have done
um looking at that connection between
this narrowed focus of attention and
improvements in exercise we do not find
that it only works for the people who
are in shape or that it backfires for
people who are out of shape it works for
everybody this is a strategy that
everybody can adopt because it's just
simply about like what do you allocate
attentional resources to what do you
sort of ignore and what do you focus on
and that and that visually induces the
same kind of illusion for everybody
regardless of whether you're overweight
or you're or you're at your target
weight
or if you're struggling to get there or
you've already accomplished where you
want to be
that visual illusion can be induced for
everybody and it has the same kinds of
consequences
terrific
earlier i made a joke about double
espresso but now i'll make a serious
statement about double espresso which is
that it contains caffeine and caffeine
as a stimulant like all other stimulants
cause a change in our visual world
the most salient one is the one that
police officers look for parents
suspecting that their kids have
ingested
substances of any kind look for which is
if somebody's pupils are unusually large
for a given visual environment
uh that is an indication of high levels
of autonomic arousal uh in the street
drug translation of this you know people
who take amphetamine or cocaine will
have very big pupils people are very
relaxed have small pupils however
everyone should know that pupil size
also is dynamically regulated by how
bright a visual environment so there are
multiple things controlling pupil size
however
we know that when we are very stressed
or very
aroused in any way positive or negative
the pupils get big
but within the visual system what that
equates to is a narrowing of the visual
aperture
so rather than ingesting sugar which i'm
guessing most of the world certainly the
us needs to ingest less sugar at least
that's what we're hearing i'm sure there
are a little few sugar you know
sucranestas out there sucrosanistas who
will also come after me with pitchforks
but let's face it most people will
probably be better off ingesting less
simple sugar
but caffeine is a great motivator
because of the internal sense of arousal
but it also narrows our visual window i
could imagine using healthy amounts of
caffeine
combined with um maybe even blinders of
the sort that um horses wear maybe like
a hoodie and a hat
maybe even blinders in order to get over
some of those more challenging
milestones is there any evidence that
people are doing this without um well
obviously people are doing it without
knowledge of how it works but are there
any studies looking at how adrenaline or
epinephrine or any other stimulants
impact motivation
i don't know honestly yeah i mean energy
drinks are a big thing now yeah
yeah for sure they are um and you know
if if you actually are more
physiologically aroused or jazzed or
whatever you know amped up um or you
just think you are
in our studies we have found that they
work in the same way that it can produce
the same kinds of consequences so and i
like that because it tells us like you
can actually change the state of your
body to induce these kinds of
experiences
or you can try to
you can just think that you can trick
yourself you can placebo effect yourself
out and produce the same kinds of
effects i had to give up coffee like 12
years ago not because not for anything
sorry
i love the taste and so decaf is my jam
um but i can't drink the caffeine
because it didn't actually do the thing
that it does for so many other people
like make me feel more energized and
more awake i just got sweaty and jittery
and anxious and i couldn't focus yeah
some people who already have a fairly
high baseline level of attention and
motivation they find that it puts the
autonomic seesaw too far in the
sympathetic tone yeah yeah and i happen
to marry the same kind of person he also
can't drink caffeine but loves a taste
of coffee the interesting thing is that
we both have to have coffee in the
morning to feel like we're ready to go
for the day so it's just part of our
routine or whatever to have that taste
and have that sensation to feel like i'm
ready to take on the day even though i
mean yeah decaf still has some caffeine
in it but we're not drinking that much
of it to probably actually
create a caffeinated experience in our
body but we're tricking ourselves
psychologically into into doing that
thing that in years past used to work
for us both
um so i think that's something to keep
in mind like you know you might have a
hoodie that you can wear to induce that
visual
illusion or you can take advantage of
the power of your mind at the end of the
day i'm a psychologist and i believe
that we have some non-zero power over
what our mind is doing what we're
thinking about what we allocate our
attention to
um that can do the same kind of thing
that a hoodie might do or that a cup of
caffeine might do
i i completely agree the visual aperture
is under our conscious control that's an
amazing feature of our visual system we
can narrow or expand it takes a little
bit of practice i think for people to
learn how to do this without moving
their head around to expand their visual
aperture and how to narrow it but what i
always tell people is um just imagine a
really troubling text message or a
really exciting text message coming in
all of a sudden you forget about the
world around you so it's it's it can be
triggered by these outside events and we
can learn how to to anchor our visual
attention
i'd love to
ask about other kinds of goals meaning
non-physical goals because many people
are trying to read more i would hope
or
learn music or a language or things that
really involve
cognitive goal lines or
internal goal lines
you know reading one chapter out of a
book each night is a tangible goal
the other that i've often wondered about
are these systems that allow you to
highlight individual lines or even words
on a page
that's a very visual obviously and
everything else is ruled out except that
word i've always wished for books that
would naturally highlight each page as i
say this someone will put in the
comments has probably existed for 10
years and i'm just showing how what a
luddite i am but um
is there any example that or
or tactic that people could use to um
better approach cognitive goals of
school work
recreational too but that don't exist in
the in the kind of fitness and sports
domain totally yeah so just a shout out
to my brother-in-law who has done some
of that research um where it does
highlight different parts of words and
paragraphs and he's found it to be an
effective way for english as a second
language learners to to pick it up that
that is that tying that vision to the
process of learning language is
effective and um so there's you know
whole cool body of
of of work and researchers looking at
that so you're right about that if you
want to mention what he does like
is is there a place that people can
learn more about that we can provide
links if uh yeah let me okay we will
provide links to those resources because
i want those resources i've been trying
to learn a second language for a long
time yeah i we i speak spanish pretty
weekly but i would love to get better at
it okay i'll approach you later but my
five-year-old son speaks spanish better
than i do at this point so
thank you
um
yeah so you know i was thinking that too
you know we started this work within the
context of exercise but of course that's
not people's only goal that they have in
life um
and it isn't mine either you know i have
interest outside of of improving my
exercise game
a couple years ago when when i was
writing the book i
i also had a child the same the same
month that i had the opportunity to like
pull all this research together is the
same month that that my son came to be
and
uh and i started to realize like i
became a lot less interesting once he
was around he was fascinating but i was
changing diapers and feeding him and
like that was it people would come over
like what's up have you been like tell
me something that's going on in your
life and like all i had to talk about
was this what was boring and i just felt
like i've lost myself i used to pride
myself on the crazy adventures and
problems i would get myself in and i was
a great storyteller and that all of a
sudden disappeared as soon as he came
into the world because he became my
world
so then i started thinking like i need
to pull back some coolness and if i ever
had it in the first place but i need to
be a cooler person than i'm coming
across right now so i decided i want to
learn to play drums i'm and i want to be
like a one hit wonder as a rock star
drummer
i only want one song because i know i'm
not gonna be able to do more than that
i'm not coordinated
at all you know like from the beginning
of time uh in fifth grade i have this
really vivid like flashbulb memory of
playing basketball for the very first
time i lost my footing i knocked into my
own teammate pushed her out of bounds
while she had the ball we lost the game
and i was not invited back on the team
for the next season
and so that you know fomented my
self-definition of uncoordinated i am a
musician
but i am not a drummer and the idea of
coordinating four limbs in real time was
like if i could do that i would be so
proud
so that's a goal that i set for myself
at the same time that my son came into
this world when i was also trying to
think about goal setting and how to
improve my ability and all of our
ability to to get a job done when you're
faced with some pretty big obstacles
so i got to practice all these
techniques that we're talking about on
myself and see for myself when i tell
people hey try this thing like narrowed
focus of attention does it help with
something like becoming a better drummer
and the answer is yeah these tactics at
least work for me sometimes under some
circumstances and they do for other
people who try them for other goals that
aren't necessarily about exercise
um you know one that i found
particularly helpful
was overcoming my bad memory that
everybody's memories are faulty right
everybody has sort of a warped
perception of the past it might be
skewed more positively than maybe we
deserve or might be skewed more
negatively if you feel that you know
what looms large in your mind as you
reflect on something from the past or
the mistakes that you've made or the
things that the social faux pas that you
had
or you know challenges that you faced at
work when you got in trouble with a boss
or with a colleague if that's what
really stands out in your mind
or the good side of all of those
possibilities we probably aren't getting
the world right and and that is
something that our brain has evolved to
give us a faulty memory to level and
sharpen to not encode and remember and
be able to recall everything that we've
experienced with accuracy and precision
and that's a problem when it comes to
assessing our own goal progress when we
want to be our own accountant and try to
determine how are we doing if i want to
become a drummer
am i on track for getting there before x
before my time runs out
am i going to make it or not and i think
that's an experience whether they want
to be a drummer or not that a lot of
people can resonate with like trying to
determine is this trajectory is this
rate of progress going to get the job
done by x amount of time well i have my
swimsuit body by summer or will i save
enough for retirement by the time i hit
65
for these goals where time is involved
and there is a deadline
we do take moments to assess our our
trajectory and if we just rely on our
memory
we're probably going to do a bad job of
assessing
[Music]
that trajectory of knowing whether we're
on pace to meeting our deadline and i
found that to be the case as i was
thinking about am i actually going to be
able to learn this song i mean i know
that it's going a lot slower than it
probably would for anybody else but to
give myself a deadline and a commitment
i decided i was going to put on a show i
was going to invite everybody i knew and
also people i didn't know and i was
going to play my one song for them
um this is while writing a book and
having just had a child yeah so when you
read the book you'll you'll see my my
story and it's the real truth of it you
know
um i mean i did play that show and it
was fine um and then i've uh because i
wrote about it in the book then some
other opportunities to play it publicly
have come up and it's like
all right i told people i can play drums
i better like show them that i actually
still can play this song
um yeah so that that's been fun i have
become a one-hit wonder if you asked me
to play the song again like like encore
it's just gonna get that same song a
second time so like literally one hit
wonder but so in the process of like
figuring out am i gonna be able to play
this show i sent out invitations like
the date is committed like people are
coming to listen to my one song
god bless them um
how's it gonna go
and and it felt awful it just felt like
i am not making progress here because
there's a lot more things that actually
are pressing right like the kid does
need to get fed i do have to go to my
day job the editor is asking for the
next draft of this book
and that is going to take precedence
like it does for so many people that
that things command your your bandwidth
even when you have this goal that you've
committed to and that you've got you
know on the books
and so i just felt this looming anxiety
about this this goal that would require
you know like didn't have to be daily
practice but like you can't you can't
cram that kind of a goal it does take
you know committed investment for a
sustained period of time
and so i had this looming anxiety that
i'm not making good enough progress
but that's because i was relying on my
memory and my brain to to recall like
how many times did you practice what was
it like the last time you practiced what
was it like when you tried to play this
bit
you know or this riff like two weeks ago
have you gotten any better since then
and it just felt like no i haven't
practiced enough i don't remember when
the last time i played was but it
definitely doesn't feel like i'm getting
any better
then i thought you know what i should
stop relying on my brain to tell me
where am i at and is is am i on an
upward slope here i need to look at the
data i love data scientists love data so
i started to collect data on myself
what i did was download this app that a
friend had told me about called the
reporter app there's lots of these kinds
of things out there basically it just
like sets up your phone to randomly ping
you with whatever questions you want
your phone to ask it records your
answers you can download the data you
can make pretty graphs to see
am i getting how what's my change and
how i've answered these questions over
time
so i did that for a month for a month i
had my phone ask me you know a couple
times a day
well maybe twice a day really did you
practice since last time i asked you
my phone says did you practice if mostly
it was no and if yes then it would
funnel a couple other questions like how
did you do how do you feel
check a couple different emotion words
now about your experience when you
played
so when i and i did that for a month
after a month went into my office
downloaded the data
and first took stock before i looked at
the numbers like how do i think i did
over the last month and i thought same
as every other month i like i didn't
really get anywhere yeah i practiced but
i still feel awful
and i cried i cried having to practice i
like was upset with myself for setting
this goal and feeling like so anxious
about it all i remember is that i cried
cried too much about this personal
conquest that wouldn't matter to anybody
else honestly it really doesn't matter
in the scope of things anyway i'm not
gonna become a drummer professionally so
who cares if i embarrass myself publicly
but what i found from the data was my
memory was totally wrong i actually had
practiced far more times than i
remembered
and when i looked at like my emotion
words that i used it was a clear upward
trajectory yeah i did cry that part i
hadn't misremembered or made up
but by the end of that month like i had
gotten a compliment from my husband who
actually is a drummer and said like hey
that wasn't that bad and then there was
like one expletive you were effing
amazing at that one thing you've been
practicing at but like okay fine he's my
husband right like he just you know so
at the moment it didn't really feel that
great and i downplayed it and as a
result it didn't stick in my brain right
i remember how stupid it felt that i
cried because i can't do this go i can't
make progress and i downplayed in my
mind the thing that actually should have
been a legitimate indicator that
progress was being made
so
all of which is to say i needed to see
to collect that data on myself and to
look at it objectively
accurately and completely because my
brain wasn't doing that for me
that visual experience of of downloading
that data and and looking at like what
was my actual experience
um gave me a better insight as i was
trying to assess the trajectory of my of
my progress i became a more accurate
accountant of my own progress which is
important for you know setting goals or
resetting them when you need to
calibrate in light of what's left to do
and how much time do you have to do it
in
i love it so basically
if i understand correctly when the when
the intermediate goals of say daily
practice or twice a day practice or
reading or math etc are not a visual
goal line it really does help to
visualize some aspect related to that
non-visual goal line in this case the
the reporter app was a useful tool i've
never heard of it i plan to to use it
i'm sure a number of people will be
interested in it sounds like there are
others out there but that's the one that
you found most useful yeah yeah there's
another one too um that is even more
visual than that than the reporter app
although that has visual components and
is really effective if you like data and
want to collect numbers on yourself or
your experience there's another one
called the one second every day app
this is really awesome because the app
is a mechanism um
to
to to record one second of your life the
goal there's such an awesome community
of people that just live by this and
love having these experiences um
and the the creator of it i got to a
chance to talk with and he has done this
he's taken a one second video of some
aspect of his life
every day for
12 years 13 years one second yeah one
second and and then what the app does is
like smash them together and give you
like a chronology of what your year or
your month or your last decade uh of
life has been like and presents it as
like a streamlined video for you so you
just see these flashes um of your life
over however long you tell the app to
create a create a montage for you
and so when you see these videos that
people have made especially those that
have been doing it for a really long
time it's fascinating i did that for
myself too i tried it one second of
today's drumming performance another
second it's not enough to capture am i
actually doing a good job of drumming or
what's my trajectory for drumming but
the guy who made it says one of the most
like awesome
one second videos that he ever made is
of a brick wall it's like you don't need
a video of that like what's the wall
doing it it's not crumbling it's not
like an earthquake land or something
like that it's just like you know
slightly jittery one second of a brick
wall and i was like how is that
motivating or exciting to you why is
that you've been doing this for 13 years
every day one second why is that the one
second that matters to you most and he
says because when it comes up in my
montage
it reminds me
of like a really horrific moment in my
family that was the first wall that i
saw when i walked out of the room having
heard that my sister-in-law
had this awful
awful uh experience her intestines
started to twist up on themselves and
not up and she uh was on the brink of
death and we had just found this out she
had just gotten into the hospital they
diagnosed this issue that required like
immediate surgery and our family was
there to hear about this and we were all
stunned that she might die like right
now she might die and that's the first
thing that i saw and it reminds me of
how precious life is how important
family is and how the rest of whatever
we were doing that day didn't matter
because we all needed to be here
together right now and that is like all
of this emotion and like purpose in life
is conjured up or reminded when he looks
at one second of a brick wall as it pops
into his video feed so if you're
visually oriented and you do want ways
to like remember what was life like what
has my year in review what is it what
does it look like that's an awesome app
one second every day that that can help
you do that these are great
recommendations and a couple of
reflections first of all
the brick wall example is a beautiful
way of
highlighting this other feature of the
visual system which is that the brain
largely thinks in symbols it's very
efficient it batches entire experiences
into symbols in this case the brick wall
can be attached to a whole set of
experiences that are very meaningful to
this individual that brick walls don't
mean that or didn't mean that uh to me
until hearing this so i think that the
it highlights the fact that the the
actual symbol is less relevant than what
we attach to that symbol but that
symbols are
so efficient that even in a one second
view of something we can attach to it
for better or for worse um the other is
that i i'm a absolute um almost rabid
proponent of people getting morning
sunlight in their eyes as the
fundamental layer of setting their
circadian rhythms and sleep and health
as a zero cost practice that believe or
not can be done any time of year
anywhere and but it does take a little
bit of effort you know you have to get
outside you can't do it through a window
or windshield for it to be efficient but
it has huge outside effects on human
health this has now been demonstrated
again and again and again and so uh i'm
going to just do a sort of call to
action if people aren't already doing
this i'm going to start using the one
second after record my
morning sunlight viewing and prove that
even through cloud cover you're getting
more photons than you are indoors and
then it's worthwhile i also would love
to do this for my next dog to go from
puppy to uh to full-sized dog and maybe
even to the end who knows um
great these are wonderful tools you've
given us a huge number of practical
tools which frankly isn't always the
case on on these podcasts we always
strive to do science and science-based
tools as our kind of a mantra but you've
given a rich set of tools here to apply
i just want to briefly backtrack to
something and then and then a final
question
earlier we were talking about how unfit
people see the world as more challenging
maybe even hills is steeper distances as
further and how
shifting people into a state of energy
either cognitively or through the
ingestion of real glucose to get an
energetic lift or maybe through caffeine
if that's within their practice and span
of healthy behaviors they could do that
you know there's so many people who are
suffering from depression which
one of the you know key features of
depression is a lack of energy even
though there can be anxiety associated
with depression
um
i have to wonder whether or not some of
these tools are being deployed or will
be deployed in the context of mental
health because
depression is this vicious loop right
people feel the lack of energy and
hopelessness and then things just look
harder and so then it just
verifies their negative world view and
it's a downward spiral that's why
medication in some cases
and social support etc can be helpful
because they feel more energized the
side effects off in our problem however
have there have there been any efforts
to implement some of these visual tools
to
create this increase in systolic blood
pressure and a kind of readiness and
willingness to lean into what people
perceive as immense challenge and if not
for anyone listening i know we have a
lot of listeners in the mental health
space and in the helping space so to
speak um i can imagine these are zero
cost right they
we all provide people are cited have the
apparati to do it
are you aware of any studies like this
or is your laboratory involved in any
studies because i just see an immense
value of implementing the sorts of tools
that you've developed yeah you know we
haven't explored that those ideas
directly so call to all the scientists
that are out there this is there's a
great opportunity to start looking at
these tools within the mental health
space you're right other researchers
though have um you know not this
use of narrowed uh like inducing a
narrowed attentional focus and can they
now feel more energized to go for a run
but they have looked at the relationship
between anxiety depression and visual
experience and found you know over
decades
evidence that people with depression or
with anxiety
what their attention is captured by
within the bigger global
surrounding world are those things that
are negative or reinforcing of their
world view now that happens for
everybody the things that are on our
mind tend to like pop out that if
whatever we're thinking about we might
start seeing
some version of it showing up in the
world around us it captures our
attention
that's an idea called priming what we're
thinking about might then lead us to
to attend to the world to see things in
a way that aligns with what we're
already thinking about it's just that
when what we're thinking about are those
depressive ruminative anxiety fearful uh
thoughts
when that is what is cognitively
accessible when that's what's going
through our mind then that's also what
captures our visual gaze so when we
think like the world is hard the world
is full of sadness
and that's the thought in our mind and
then we start seeing the people with
frowns on their faces or who are
experiencing anxiety and
and that's what captures our attention
even when there's other people around
that might not be seeing the world or
experiencing the world that way
it becomes reinforcing when i think that
the world is is threatening and then i
notice the threats that are around me
that confirms what i'm thinking which
heightens my anxiety or my fear uh and
then it further leads me to to narrowly
focus on those elements of the
environment that are aligned with that
worldview it's really hard to get out of
that like that's where the vicious cycle
can come from
so that has been you know really well
established within the medical community
this this selective attention relating
to uh states of mental uh unwellness
um that's that's been pretty well
established and um
and so there's been some interventions
done with people that have depression or
anxiety trying you know saying like you
know here's an array a photograph of a
bunch of different faces yes it's
artificial it kind of looks like a page
from a yearbook a high school yearbook
but look for the faces that are smiling
look at the faces that are smiling like
try right now spend 10 minutes
having your eyes focus on those and look
at those people
that it is an effective intervention and
trying at improving
people's sense of self-efficacy of what
can i accomplish next they feel a little
bit more energized it doesn't cure
depression it doesn't cure anxiety i
mean these are literal physical
afflictions that we have so that's not a
quick fix but it can produce a temporary
change that might be a way to start
getting out of that rut
yeah and i think nowadays there's an
increasing attention on
tools that will help people orient as
they are start to veer towards suicidal
depression or veer back into a
depressive episode or anxiety episode i
mean
you know that trying to reverse an
entire syndrome or set of syndromes is
far more complicated likewise in the
health space just trying to get people
to deploy real-time tools to adjust
their anxiety or to exercise more often
and so on
as a kind of a final but also kind of
high level question i i'm imagining
that and i i plan to use this visual
goal setting of spotlighting um i've
been using it actually for some time on
runs it works really well yesterday i
took a run near the waterfront here and
the entire i think i did it somewhat
incorrectly the entire run i was
thinking about getting back to the
statue
which i started but i did find that i
ran fastest in the final 20 meters which
admittedly wasn't fast at all
but it was faster than what preceded it
um
so it works and it makes perfect sense
as to how it works
you've done
other studies um exploring some of the
other features of vision like the
luminosity how bright something is and
how people perceive it that was in a
completely different context but is
there a kind of a higher level kind of a
black belt version of what we're talking
about here where not only am i focusing
on a specific visual location as an
intermediate or a long-term goal
or i'm using an app to ask me a question
and tap into how i'm feeling create a
visual representation of my motivational
state but that i'm also
making my phone as bright as possible
i'm also trying to take that visual
window and actually pay attention to
more of the details at that location or
is this simply a matter of kind of uh in
in geek speak visual neuroscience we
would just call this like low spatial
frequency just sort of grabbing a black
and white snapshot of something here or
there in my mind
if i attach more detail and effort to
the specific thing that i'm focused on
is there any evidence that's more
effective
it certainly you know changes what our
brains are doing so you know how do we
define effectiveness that's a question
for philosophers and that scientists
like keep me running yeah
it will when you use it towards the end
of your run just like you've picked up
on
um
yeah so you know there's there's cool
studies that neuroscientists not not i
not coming from my lab that
neuroscientists have done looking at
what is it what is it doing to your
brain when you've decided that you're
going to focus your attention on on this
element of the world and not pay
attention to something else
is that just sort of like tricking your
thoughts or is it doing something
different to something more basic more
low level and the answer is yes so
there's an area of the brain brain the
fusiform face area it's part of our
brain that's really specialized for for
making sense of faces it's important as
a social species to to pay attention to
other people pay attention their faces
what they're trying to communicate
through their face so our brain has
developed a really specialized um
central area for doing that
then uh and so people so these
neuroscientists will present like a face
to somebody but superimposed over that
uh is a house or something else that is
less special to us as a social human
species
um and so both of those things because
it's sort of like both images are sort
of transparent overlaid over one another
um
it you know our eyes are getting both of
those images in and our brain is getting
both of those images in but we can
will ourselves to focus on the house
just really pay attention to the
features of the house even though
everything about that face is still
there too or pay attention to the face
and just tell me like what is it that
you are deciding that you want to hold
on to that you want to look at right now
and you can see that the brain is
responding to that so when people are
saying like i'm really i'm really seeing
that face the details of the face i'm
paying attention to the face
even though we know their eyes are also
looking at and engaged with the contents
of the house that's right there smacked
on top the fusiform face area lights up
and when they're saying like now i'm
really focused on the house now we see
activation the fusiform face area
decline and and other areas of
you know the the brains neurological
rest real estate start to engage
so um
yeah i think you know there's something
to it that you know we can at a high
level
our brains are responding to our
psychology as well and we have that
great power to really you know
with intention with practice decide how
do i want to engage with the world and
can it produce
real change in our in our bodies and in
the way that we experience the world the
answer is yes
fantastic
well
you've given us a ton of
mechanistic and uh conceptual and
practical information so i'm speaking
for a lot of people when i say thank you
for taking the time out of your schedule
it's kids and running a lab and teaching
at the university and your book which uh
we will point people to and provide a
link to uh is a wonderful resource and
we hope to have you back again thank you
so much this is a great conversation
thank you thanks
thank you for joining me today for our
discussion about motivation goal seeking
and research supported tools for
achieving your goals with dr emily
balchettas if you're learning from and
or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our youtube channel that's
a terrific zero-cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on apple and spotify and on both
apple and spotify you can leave us up to
a five-star review
please leave us any comments or
suggestions or ideas for future guests
or questions about particulars of any
podcast episode in the comment section
on youtube we do read all the comments
please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning of today's
episode and check out athletic greens
that's the best way to support this
podcast
in addition please check out our neural
network newsletter that is a zero cost
newsletter available to anyone you just
provide an email and we do not share
your email with anybody you simply go to
hubermanlab.com you go to the menu you
look for the neural network newsletter
and by signing up for the newsletter you
can get summaries of podcast episodes
detailed lists of protocols related to
podcast episodes again all zero cost we
don't share your information and if
you'd like to see examples of previous
newsletters they're also available on
our website hubermanlab.com if you're
not already following us on social media
we are huberman lab on both twitter and
instagram there i cover science and
science related tools some of which
overlap with the contents of the
hubermann lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the information on the
huberman lab podcast again it's huberman
lab on instagram and huberman lab on
twitter and as mentioned at the
beginning of today's episode we are now
partnered with momentous supplements
because they make single ingredient
formulations that are of the absolute
highest quality and they ship
international
if you go to livemomentus.com
huberman you will find many of the
supplements that have been discussed on
various episodes of the huberman lab
podcast and you will find various
protocols related to those supplements
so thank you once again for joining us
today for our discussion about the
science and science related tools of
motivation goal seeking and pursuit and
last but certainly not least thank you
for your interest in science
you